Hello Freak bitches,
and I was like,
well,
what is this whole fitness connection to
hunting?
Like why do they need to be in shape?
I'm like,
I'm in pretty good shape.
Like what's the big deal?
Well,
I went with Rinella and when I went with
one of the things I realized that point,
I got pretty winded going up these
fucking hills,
hiking,
tires,
you out,
especially high altitude and then I see
your videos online and I was like,
what the fuck is this guy into?
And then as I go deeper and deeper into
it,
I realized,
oh,
this is like an extreme pursuit.
This is not just something just go out
and do.
This is something that's really hard to
do.
And a lot of people there,
I've,
I've read this one article,
but there's one guy who was unsuccessful
12 years in a row,
elk hunting for it.
Finally shot an elk like 12 years.
Like how many times did this guy go out?
How many days did he camped in the
forest?
How many days did he try to stock and
get winded or snap on a twig?
At the last minute or you know,
the,
the elk season and bolts it.
Most people are unsuccessful.
Yeah.
I mean nine out of 10 every year.
Unsuccessful.
I think it's more than that for elk
hunting.
With archery it,
it's about,
it's about 10 percent.
Is it 10 percent?
Yeah.
So nine out of 10 are unsuccessful.
So people who don't hunt who see dead
stuff all the time,
they think,
oh,
you just go out and kill an Adam,
right?
No,
right.
Most 90 percent don't.
It is really hard and it's just like
until you're out there,
you got the bone in your hand and you're
trying to close in on that animal and
you're trying to do everything right
from a to z with.
And there's so many variables during
that whole path is just like,
it seems impossible sometimes,
you know,
even even for me after 30 years.
So in a sense,
psychologically when you talk about
postmodernists and their rejection of
these classic male structures are,
what they doing is realizing that
they're not going to compete in the
classic as stated male hierarchy.
So they're creating their own version of
it.
Sure.
That's the creative element.
While we,
he,
we asked earlier,
what's the motivation of these
pathological guys who are out there like
bolstering up the feminists?
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
they don't compete any other way.
They don't compete.
They figured out how to compete.
They compete as allies.
Let's say.
[inaudible] very sneaky.
Yeah.
And that's how everybody always
describes them to when you.
I mean it's almost like a,
we,
I avoid doing it because it just almost
feels gross to label them like that,
but that's,
that is the way you think of male
feminists.
You think of them as sneaky
and it's creepy and discriminated
discriminatory towards classic male
behavior.
Well,
it,
no wonder they haven't got a hope of
competing in that hierarchy.
Wow,
that's deep.
That is deep.
This is going to be hurtful to a lot of
people.
So a lot of people listening to this
right now,
very upset.
You asked earlier why,
why the postmodernists don't like blunt
speech.
That's why man,
you know,
it's like the truth is something that
Burns,
it burns off deadwood and people don't
like having their dead wood burn it off
often because they're like 95 percent
deadwood and I'm not being an.
Believe me,
I'm not being snide about that.
It's no joke.
When you start to realize how much of
what you've constructed of yourself is
based on deception and lies,
that is a horrifying realization and it
can easily be 95 percent of you.
Your things.
You say things you act out,
you know it's well,
you see that in Pinocchio,
which I often you discuss,
you know Pinocchio,
when he gets corrupt,
as he,
as he matures,
he first learns to lie and then he
becomes a brain jackass on pleasure
island.
It's like,
and he's threatened by the underground
authoritarians,
right?
They're going to sell them to the salt
mines.
It's like,
yeah,
that's for sure.
It's exactly right man.
So then you figure out your uh,
brain jackass and you're lying all the
time.
That's a terrible realization.
And then all that needs to be burned
away and no,
people don't like that.
It ties into lake a misconception,
is that a natural,
like a funny thing,
like when I worked in the video game
industry,
there's a platform games,
you jim from little platforms and seven
times the EPA light platforms that move
around and Mario type things in some
video games,
when you jump up on a moving platform
and then jump down and fall down,
you will fall down because platform
moves out from underneath you.
Sometimes you jump up and you move with
the platform and you land on.
It depends on what the program did right
now a friend of mine was doing a video
game and one of the programs that said,
Oh,
if you jump up and then jump down,
the platform should have moved out from
underneath you.
So you should be able to like a,
you should be able to,
uh,
you know,
this is the way we should program the
physics.
And then my friend Matt said,
no,
that's wrong.
And he couldn't convince this other guy.
So eventually what happened?
He says,
right.
What we're gonna do is we're going to go
out onto the road with my pickup,
my pickup truck,
I'm going to get in the back and you're
going to drive along at 30 miles an hour
and I'm going to jump straight up in the
air and we'll get to see whether I land
in the truck or a land on the road.
So they did this experiment and the guy,
the other guy who was driving the truck
was totally expecting him to late jump
up in that full out of the back of the
truck because the truck went moved dog
because he's moving the same speed as
the trucks may jumps up and then he
lands back in the truck and this that.
This is illustrating the video game
program.
I had the exact same misconception that
the flat earth is due because they say,
well,
what if the earth is moving so fast?
Why can't you just go up in a
helicopter,
hover a bit,
wait for the Earth to move underneath
you?
Then go back down again.
It's just,
you know,
it's completely backwards physics
because you already moving,
so you'd have to slow down to zero a
which is the same as speeding up and
relatively speaking.
So the point is that anyone can make
misconceptions about physics like that.
Yeah.
And it's easy to get sucked into that
and it's actually quite hard to break
them even flow.
This is reasonable guy who was like,
you know,
video game program,
but who presumably knew something about
physics.
He was convinced that Matt was going to
fall out to the back of the truck and
quite possibly die,
but they still let him do the
experiment.